I just want to say is right as we start at the top of the show, I just want to say yeah, this is our 52nd episode of smart 22 that's a year in a year that's a one a year freaking year whole year God this is the 52nd episode of smart Oh my god, so yeah, let's get to it. This is I'm not sure if you guys are aware, but this is our 52nd episode which means we have hit one year one year started the nonsense Yeah, 52 weeks. Isn't that amazing is that incredible remember when we first started talking about doing this? Yeah, I do Yeah, I thought it was really just gonna be three four or five weeks Maybe something like that and then we'd a covert would be over and we'd be back to our our day jobs But god, this is thank you everyone for listening. Yeah, thanks
I'm letting will Sean and I continue to visit with one another every week Can I just say that friendship alive for me it? Really spending this last year with you guys in this way even more than the normal it's been a really great sort of antidote to it otherwise not amazing year and And being able to hang out with you guys has been fucking a real savior to me anyway for my mental health I really mean that likewise. It's been a nice thing to be able to count on once a week I feel so lucky to be even closer to you guys and have this experience to echo what will said together and And and and the opportunity to laugh together, which to me is life
Yeah, and it's not just the three of us Obviously, it's our it's our whole team and the other part of that team is Bennett barbecue and Rob Arm your and Michael Terry But we always know that Rob Rob's name is always Rob. I'm your arm your Is that how you say it Sean because Jason? Yeah, I like to say that the phonetic way I like saying Rob. I'm Jay Irv. Well, that's how it's spelled. Yeah, that's I'm saying that's instead of arm your Because even he doesn't know how you're supposed to say it like he doesn't even know how to say Rob Oh, he doesn't know how to say the Rob. I'm your arm your arm your Bennett barbecue. That's easy to say and Michael Terry That's easy to say. Yeah, but they make it happen. Those guys are fucking champs and honestly, it's
We wouldn't be here without that. I want to see I want to see the socials line up and appreciation for Bennett Rob and Michael Yeah, truly honestly sincerely. Thank you to anyone who has been spending some time with us and Yes, letting us keep the the lights on as I think they say yeah and putting up with our nonsense and knowing that we're just here Having fun just like you guys honestly. I'm so glad you guys don't have to pay for this. It's free. It's priced, right? But we can but we can announce right Jason. We can't officially say that we are gonna do a Smartlist tour a line. You're doing a smart list tour. We're going on tour. That's right. We're smart list is going on tour We are going to six cities in North America. Yes, we have a ton to discuss dates venues even a special promo code for our listener Yeah, yeah, but but that's too much to make our guest wait for so that's gonna be at the end
But right now, okay, we got to get to what might be our greatest of all time Oh, oh, yeah, we have with us someone that would be best described as a true force He's taken the gifts he's been given and the influence he holds and pointed them towards a full menu of things That are truly too long to mention in an intro However, a couple to throw out there would be the creation of a world-class elementary school and a family foundation He's part owner will of one of the world's most famous soccer teams. What and he has starred in five films He's married to his high school sweetheart. He has three kids. He was recruited to play football by Notre Dame But instead this fool took a gamble on basketball where he just can't seem to find any success guys
Please meet mr. LeBron James Did I have you fooled that was good intro right there Jason that's pretty good intro You've never been introduced like that before right people go on about Jason. That was a good one It's a good one. Oh my god But truly let let me tell you something LeBron going through and I don't do a lot of research as the guys will attest I will go to a Wikipedia page though your page is more of a book and I just I just hit effort real quick I didn't know where to begin. There's so much stuff But truly the stuff about philanthropy and family and all that stuff
We're gonna get into because I think everyone else knows the other stuff, but men go ahead Well, you got something to say first of all, I was gonna say I just took off. I was wearing a Lakers t-shirt This is crazy I just took it off because I worked out and you don't want to get into my workout routine LeBron because it's I bet he'd love to get it. Well, these shoulders, you know, they don't quit. I mean What about the Liverpool element that was a real shocker to me that's you know, I'm not a smart guy But will did you know that who wills a huge soccer fan LeBron? I read that I'm a big Liverpool I'm a big Liverpool supporter and and I have been for a number of years and I'm friendly with a bunch
But I had read that you were part owner, which is so crazy because I'm like another thing that LeBron and I have in common Oh, yeah, there it is. Shoulders and the soccer stuff Dominating the shoulders in Liverpool. LeBron, I have to say this is This is especially exciting for me because I know who you are. Oh, yeah We've had a few athletes on the show and and Shawn just goes to he starts playing Candy Crush and we pick it up After the guest goes away Thrilling I I I can't believe you're here. This is so exciting. Thank you No, I have so many things I want to say for to ask you that I've just thought about one of the things is
You're such an incredible Jason's right. You are a force and you've been such an incredible You're so iconic already, which is which is crazy because you're you're still a relatively young man a lot younger than we are We can be his dad. We could be his dad But you've done you've done so much and and it's and it's so impressive to watch you do it and you do it with such There's a grace about you because you the part of the problem I think about being on top and I wouldn't know but part of the problem is that you are subjected to a lot of you know Slings and arrows, you know from from people from all sides not the least of which is I think every year since you Got drafted people are like, who's the greatest of all time? Is it like they have there's a poll every six hours
ESPN will put it on their page like and who is LeBron greater than Michael Jordan? It's like guys. He's LeBron He's his own person that that shit must get exhausting be honest. It must be exhausting No, it can it can't be exhausting. Well, I mean you said it but um, you know I've always looked at it like anytime you compared or you even mentioned with the greats that ever played this game It's just become humbling for me because you know the same people they put me in a category with or saying Compare this compare this to that guy or the same guys that I looked up to for inspiration when I was growing up And I needed that inspiration, you know growing up in the inner city here in Akron, Ohio So, you know to have you know, the Michael Jordan's and to have the you know
The Kobe Bryant's to have King Griffey juniors and a Dion Sanders all those Unbelievable sports figures, you know what when I when I needed it, you know, they helped me So it's like wow you guys are comparing me to these greatest players that I've ever seen when I was growing up It's just like it's such humbling man. Yeah, the the stats will certainly Put you in that category without even trying but what you've what you've done off the court the stuff You don't need to do but you find yourself drawn to do and as a result of your success on the court Has given you access to do and the capital to do. I find really really admirable I'm envious of it
There's a there's a drive though that that has to fuel that because you're tired all bet doing the stuff That is your day job. How do you find Jason's tired for you? I'm sure you have a great infrastructure of people that can identify some Charitable endeavors that are worthy of your time and and and the attention that you can put on them I'm sure you rely on them a bit But a lot of that's got to be your own self-drive and to motivate those people to be diligent in how they assess certain Charitable organizations and whatnot. Well, where does that drive come from that that that drive of philanthropy? Now you just I mean you said it Jason
I think for me that the drive comes from my upbringing and You know growing up the way I grew up, you know, I'm a part of a single parent household just me and my mother no siblings You know not much care my mom worked on and off, you know my whole Childhood so, you know every day was kind of a struggle for us as a family So I felt that if I ever was even put into a position This is also part of my inspiration to growing up if I was ever put in a position where I succeed at doing anything And I can make any kind of dollars anything as far as capital that I want to give a lot of it back I want to give a you know a lot of it back to my community
Because I understand what those kids are going through on a day-to-day basis because I've walked those same streets I've tackled those same corners. I know the hardships of what a single parent household kid could feel like and the Pressures and the adversity and all that stuff that comes with it. So and to see that change. Yeah. Yeah I mean see the change of happen from your efforts. It's got to be Unbelievably rewarding. Yeah, I mean yeah, we to hear some of the family shawning like well, you know you guys I mean just to see some of the families come and tell, you know, either You know the falconty members that's at my school or the teachers that you know
I've changed their lives or tell my mother because now my mom is huge into the foundation and she welcomes a lot of issue part of it What yes, she's a she's like one of the head advisory boards of my foundation where I basically have an apartment complex here as well Yeah, where I welcome a lot of the underprivileged families in and we set them up with Roman board You know that we're not in a position where they came, you know, afford their own living. So, you know, it's pretty cool My mom welcomes all these families in that's awesome. So she's set kind of like an ambassador. Yeah, exactly But you say like you came up, you know, you talk about your own childhood and record to recognize look I really struggled and so I want to be able to give back and really do it in a way in a really practical way Lot of people talk about it, but you actually do it
And you know look at Sean Sean grew up you had a tougher, you know childhood and stuff and you turned your back on your community Yeah, he went the other way. He kept things simple He lives in a mansion and he spends his money on No, but surely free though. Yeah, and Jason doesn't know what the what you know Jason jumped the line famously to in line for the first iPhone. So like we all have our own Let me just say this to you you could have a single incarnation But my point is this my point is you could have gotten you you've had everything you've had so much success You could have just sailed away on a yacht and never looked back
But he's finding time to do that too, right? We get some yacht hours each year. Yes Wait, have you been on a yacht with LeBron and you haven't told Oh, but I know how to get to the Daily Mail, right? I mean So so you're a kid so you're a kid you're hanging out and you're thinking boy If I can ever get this jump shot to really go down in a consistent way I might be able to get myself to a place where I could either get out of here or stay here and and and help Give back to this man. What was the moment when you thought to yourself? Oh, you know what this is gonna work And I think I've got a very realistic chance of making it and now I'm starting to think about what I'm gonna do
If I do make it starting your plans about Philanthropy and you know because a lot of kids fantasize in school when I'm older I want to be a teacher so I don't have to do any of the schoolwork and I can get like what was that moment like and what were Those first few plans you remember that was there a moment. Yeah, I feel like yeah the beginning of my junior year I was 16 years old and so it's right after my sophomore year in the summer going into my junior year. I was on the cover of Sports Illustrated That'll do it. They doubt they dubbed me the chosen one at 16 years old And a lot of pressure by the way, no pressure Right, right and the jinx of the cover on top of it all right right and the jinx of the cover
And so a lot of NBA execs were talking and they were saying that you know if I entered the draft You know right now I could be the number one pick and you know, but you know do it all those things so I felt like I seen the success that I was having and The reason that I knew I wanted to come back and give back to my community is because I knew the success that I was having Yes, it had to do with my God-given abilities and my talent and me putting in the work But the support that I had for my coaches and my friends and my mom They stayed on my ass every day like listen. Yeah, this is what we're going. This is what we doing We all listen. We have an opportunity to make this bigger than even what other people are saying
Let's not fuck it up right? Oh You know, so, you know, it's tough on a 16 year old because listen me and my friends we want to do You know first year driving we want to go to house parties We want to go, you know, we hang with the other high school kids and do kid things, but you know Yeah, right, you know Jason knows about the kid things right like driving off the Warner Brothers lot when you're 16 But with your but LeBron with with your kids your own kids What an incredible story you have to pass down to them about your struggle and then how you turn it around and how you're giving back Is it something that they get and if they don't get it you grind it in their brains?
It's like you've got to keep looking at me. You've got to keep looking at my story. You have got to learn how to give back I mean, it's so cool to have a dad that That does all that there's absolutely nothing I can do Nothing I can do to give them the same moment or aspirations or like drive that I had It's just to I mean you can't teach ambition. No, I can't I know I grew up in Akron, Ohio in the inner city You know and the hood is what we call it the projects and my kids are growing up four years in Miami on South Beach And now four are going on five years in Brentwood. So Yeah, you know and when we were here for those four-year run when I was in Cleveland, they were younger
You know, we're in it. We're now in the suburbs So I went to public schools and challenging public schools until I got the high school because of my basketball ability But these kids are growing up in private schools. So the one thing that I can do is it's still of the morals And what we do in this house? Yeah, and this is how you need to represent yourself when you leave the house as a young man I got two boys two teenage boys. I got a daughter that's seven years old So you give them the blueprint and then you got to let them, you know, we I hope that they have some adversity You know, they need some hardships They hope they find some along this way because you really only know who you are and you only gonna be able to come back from
Situations because the best teacher in life is experience. Yeah. Yeah, and I bet you lean on mom a lot too, right? Your wife I bet your wife is Incredibly important to with all the time you're spending on the road I mean, I the three of us know as well The amount of time you spend away from home is immense and you really have to lean on your your partner To like my wife is part-time dad too, you know, yeah for sure They're literally the boss of the household like we're we're gone so much We all know that that it's hard for us to come home and be like, okay. This is the hell we doing
This is how we doing it like dad you've been going for four or five months straight like like dad Okay, yeah, like mom already told us go sit down dad Your kids are gonna have a little bit of adversity with that that sunset traffic coming out of Brentwood The Barrington is just And now back to the show, you know, you do all this stuff and you've got this school Where you you provide opportunities and Jason brought it up I love the way by the way as you were talking about growing up you kept saying We you know that the people who are around you're saying we have an opportunity we have an army
You know, we got to keep going We got to keep doing the things the way that you were part of something and that you relied like as you talked about these people That you leaned on I love that you talked about in that way I think it's so Important to sort of to have that kind of support system But as you talked to kids who don't have the job shot that you had as you what do you say to those kids who are like look man I hit the lottery. I had a tremendous amount of skill. I had great people around me I'd God-given gifts and I had the willpower to do it. That was the perfect storm
That's not going to be the experience for ninety nine point nine percent of the kids No question. No question about it. That's the one thing that we have like at my school here We don't we don't even have a basketball complex at my school, you know, but we have we have a art We have an art room. We have a music lab. We have a technology lab world computers Like so like we're we're we're every single day asking our kids What do you want to do, you know, a lot of them say sports but a lot of them like listen I want to be a doctor, you know So we have doctors that come in to talk to our kids a lot of them say, okay
I want to be a cop, you know We got cops, you know Obviously at the front door when they walk in it's so kind to our kids and they can talk to them and give them guidance Like what do you want to be like what do you want to be? What's your aspirate? What are your dreams? You might not even know what your aspirations are right now, but you do have dreams We all had dreams about what we wanted to be so, you know, if it's something that they have passion about We try to bring it to the school and try to give them the resources to you know, let's let's see if we could tap into it and We might you might fail that first one, you know, let's let's try it again
Or you might say I don't let's try something else, you know, that's all about being a kid You try so many things until you finally figure out. Okay. Oh, this is what I want to do And then let's try to give them the resources. That's that's my whole thing I want to just give them the resources to be able to tap into whatever they want to do I love that and now I want to get I want to ask you stuff about playing in the game because you know I played basketball when I was a kid and I was like, I'd be like buying a child No, I did and and I was like when everybody went when the ball would be Here we go
When you did when you're talking when you're saying the LeBron you're describing playing basketball the LeBron James I'm sorry. I interrupt. So when I was a kid I played about your experience playing basketball I played basketball and whenever there was a rebound and everybody would run to the end of the other opposite end of the court I'd go go. No, you guys go. I'll catch. I'm right behind I'm so close. I'm I'm I'm just gonna take a beat, but I'm right behind you guys But wait, but here's the thing But I look at you because I've been to a couple Lakers game live courts I was lucky enough to have courtside seats and see you
I have to say seeing seeing seeing you play live and seeing the whole team play life is so much more thrilling than TV But TV is thrilling too, but to see it live. It's just unbelievably exciting and and I don't I couldn't even possibly begin to understand How you do what you do, but here's the thing here comes a question guys. It's worth the wait When you're running death, I mean it seems like it's you get tired Yeah Endless amount of energy who cuts the oranges to the parents take turns I'm bringing oranges for half-time
You've been doing it for so long tired No, God LeBron, I got a question Here's now. What about what about your foot? Wait, I want to know about injuries. My whole point was asking about injuries Okay, so I'm obsessed with medical stories, right? I I host another podcast It's called a hypochondria actor because I'm an actor who's a hypochondria anyway, and and I just wanted to know What kind of injuries have ever had what was the worst one you've ever had where you and did you play through it?
The worst injury I had tore my groin Two years ago. How does that have a plan all Christmas Day in Golden State? Shawn did the same thing in Mika nose Yeah But it was so worth it Sitting up there and hit hard. Oh My I swear if I was in Mika nose it's on my groin. I've been working too. I'll tell you daily mail would love it Oh, I know I did not keep playing. I feel like my balls was ripping off. Yep
Oh Really yeah Something that I think is very very interesting among many things is Randy Maverick and Rich now now fellas These are these are three of his best friends from growing up and you guys figured out a Sort of a four-legged table to go through the rest of your life and everyone kind of talked about I would imagine What their lanes would be and how we can be a unit and we can drive this thing? What was what was what were those conversations like and how early did that start? Well, let's start. I mean it was it was early on after my
My rookie year in the NBA. I Realized that 19 years old that the representation that I was under at that time Wasn't best suited for me and it wasn't gonna allow me to grow not only as a basketball player But also as a I wanted to you know be a businessman as well. I wanted to get control of my my business and it was something that was Unprecedented and shone upon in the NBA because everyone always expects for you to have a agent NBA agent But when I you know part of ways with my NBA agent and agency and started my company LRMR with Maverick rich and Randy People were like they're uneducated. They don't know anything about the sports world. They don't know anything about business It is gonna be a complete disaster
For me, I didn't give a damn about what they were talking about because I feel like if I'm Who are the people to trust more than the people that I know? And we can all learn together because I don't want to to learn at a rate Then now these guys are so far below me, then how can I ever bring them into any room? Let's all learn at the same time. Let's learn at the same rate. Let's take bumps and bruises Let's take let's fail at the same time while we all going along in this journey So when we get to a point where oh, we've done so much. We've learned so much. We've experienced You know failure, but we've done it together. So we know how to we you know, when the next point come up
We know how to attack it. So, you know, that was my whole mindset I think it's just incredible that not only were you guys successful at that you didn't fall on your face They did negotiate great contracts for you. You have found incredible business opportunities But I'll bet what you're probably most proud of is that you were able to navigate all of that and still maintain the friendship that it I'm sure it got complicated at times But that you guys stayed so close and so trusting and probably felt very equal Everybody respected each other. I mean, I'm sure that takes a ton of work. It's like a marriage, right? No, absolutely I mean every day every single day and we're still going I mean and we're still, you know
We've been in this for almost 20 years now, but I mean, we're all relatively still young. I mean, I'm obviously I'm the youngest out of the crew But I'm 36 my guys are in there, you know early 40s or mid 40s And you know, we're in a good place today But we want to continue to climb because it's you know, we want to continue to build and build Relationships and and build great content for for everyone. Yeah, yeah And you get to do with the people you get to do with the guys like you said that you trust But who are your friends and that's nice and we go through the same thing here I mean, we get to do this podcast with I get to do with two guys that I love and who are my friends and I'm not the youngest
But I I'm I sort of I'm not in my I play 38, but you know, I'm sort of I don't think so I mean, I could probably or like a 40 or just like a kind of a rugged 40 But the point is We we get to do and I get that and that's it's part of the experience I mean, you might as well do the experience the way you want I love the way you also you answer that like you're like people say that you guys didn't know what you're doing You don't know the sports world and all that stuff and you're like, I don't give a damn like who gives a shit There are always who gives it their life is way too short
And that was kind of like my earlier question like it's part of the problem about being on top is people always have Opinions and you hear it all the time and you you do, you know In credit you have a lot of people who support you and you're so great at what you do But you always have this really organic kind of natural way about you and you're very much You're very authentic and that comes across and I think that that's so admirable It's send such a great message of like all these all these critics to people who want to I remember though Do you remember the the decision Sean? Do you know what the decision was? So when LeBron was gonna leave Cleveland the first time he was deciding and tell me if I got it wrong or whatever
But I think this right and you're deciding where you were gonna go And there were people who criticize it who still to this day. Yeah have time on their hands enough They want to go back Relitigate something from 15 it was international news that whole thing. Yeah, I was So what let him do it how he wants to do it. Yeah, he's not it. He's not your experience. Why are you mad about it? Yeah, yeah, I love that buddy, man, you know, so at the end of the day, I mean, you know You'd be so successful you try to be so successful to where when we reap the benefits I do with my friends So, you know, when I see Sean and Mika knows and I'm with my guys that we can all
We can all tear our groins together and have some So when you're talking about having success and having the the courage to try to have success in other areas one of the things You said was content and of course you got Space Jam coming up which looks incredible Yeah, where where does this drive for for entertainment for for acting producing and all that stuff Were you always a fan of the entertainment industry? Is that something that that just kind of grown? Yeah Jason always man When I was a kid, you know, not only was the inspiration coming from like sports figures There was also coming from like, you know TV shows that I was watching like I always felt like I wish I was the fresh Prince of Bel Air, so I was I was the Fresh Prince of Akron, Ohio, you know, I was in the suburbs of Akron, Ohio and Bath Township
And I could you know look up to a mansion, you know cover from the inner city like the Fresh Prince of Brentwood Yeah, yeah, the Fresh Prince of Brentwood like I've always I love that storyline or like, you know I wish you know at times like, you know, it's you know, just being in certain movies like action movies and things that nature growing up so like Yeah, like the the the passion of watching that and seeing that and being a kid like just trying to find any inspiration That's where it kind of came from and I've always kind of respected that I did not had no idea of the damn hours that you guys Hours but I always let me ask you this like look at what Dwayne Johnson has done. Could you ever see yourself? What at some point retiring and then starting and having an incredible career as an action star in movies?
I'm not against that. Yeah, I mean listen to rock man Dwayne Johnson is incredible He's I mean shit. I was watching him when he was in the WWE, right, you know growing up and he had all the he had all the hair at that time, you know But you but you but you could crush that LeBron LeBron you'd be fantastic I've seen you act you you get it you absolutely get it And you've got all the charisma and the size to be carrying around two or three weapons When you I remember when you first hosted SNL my my ex-wife at the time Amy was on the show I remember I was kind of we actually met briefly I wouldn't expect to remember but we at the time everybody talking about how natural you were kind of to what Jason was saying
Like you were really great on that episode. Yes Thank you. Yeah, yeah I just wanted to have a hello, but I like having a great time man and just diving into it and you know I like like comedies That's like really my thing because I'm a fucking Jokester with me and my friends and all we do is like rank on each other and joke on each other But it's fun man. What's the thing that's making you laugh right now? Are you are you watching a show or a movie or what's what's your what's your brand of humor?
Are you more of like a money Python silly guy or or more more cerebral kind of dry humor? I'm a little bit of everything. So I'm a I'm a I'm a Seinfeld funny guy. Yeah, I'm also like a Wedding Crashers funny guy, right? Yeah I'm like and I'm every a road trip kind of guy. Oh, like I'm any I'm all of that like and I'm also like like scary movie Like those type of right. Yeah, silly Yeah, yeah all over the genre of comedies Yeah, and where are you taking a lot of these in on the plane in between games or you a kind of guy that sits at home and nests and Just gets all comfy on the couch. Yeah, I'm a guy that gets comfy on the couch
That's what I'm gonna do. I would a glass glass of wine on the couch. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, for sure Now do you let your kids watch our rated comedies? I do my boys do how old were they when you let them start to watch stuff That was really kind of edgy edgy comedy cuz I'm dealing with that right now with my 14 year old daughter Yeah, yeah, I'll let I'll let my my boys start watching around like 10. Yeah 11 years old. Yes, my daughter can watch certain but not I don't let her watch just she's only six going on seven So I'm gonna wait till she get a little older. Where are you on cursing my kids? Wait, Jason, what did you just let your franny watch something? What was it? It's pulp fiction and
She was confused in a couple of spots and I didn't bother The epi-pen yeah Jason and this weekend are you guys you're you're we aren't this weekend Aren't you guys watching human centipede? Wait, wait LeBron, where are you on cursing my 14 year old? I'm allowing her to now I haven't started complaining about her cursing or else, you know, she's not like a like a like a sailor, but You know, she's just casually using the s-word or the f-word or whatever And I'm like, well, I guess I was doing that afford or she's doing that with her friends So why can't you do that with us? Where are you with that the kids kids?
Walking around the house. So my boys are they have an exception to the rule of cursing when they're playing sports So they can curse when there's playing sports. Yes, because yes, they could curse when they play in sports Because it's a lot of emotion. I get it, you know, but then you get teed up, right? Yeah, you know, they can get teed up But they don't my kids don't mess with the refs much But like if they you know missing assignment, they say fuck or they like or something have a damn or shit like, you know But but my oldest son and his past tournament over the 4th of July weekend a kid was talking a little smack to him Oh, and he told him to fuck off and I started laughing
I saw you in that tournament and the reason I saw you is because it was on like one of the on the internet and I'm thinking like Who's letting these photos be taken of this high school basketball game? Like what is going on? Oh my god? Are there photographers or yes, yes, there's what's families with phones? No, they really had no there were families with big lens cameras like their own set really Trying to capture this stuff and sell it to the internet. Yeah, they capture it. They yeah. Yeah, so yep. Yep Maybe you should turn around and tell them to fuck off Right, I should take a page out of my son's book So wait, so so if he spills a cereal in the house and he says god damn it son of a bitch, that's not okay
Right, that's when he's got to go to his room. Yeah Hey, what the hell you talk? Oh, oh, sorry And if you were to punish him what what are the punishments like with my kids? It's got it you take away the iPad and that that straightens them out. What's what's the kryptonite there? We tried taking away his video game system before Okay, he still had his phone right and then without his phone. He okay, didn't he had his company had his iPad Yeah, and then he had his desktop if he didn't have his desk. He had his desktop They what are you gonna do? Sending them to the room is actually not a punishment. They know
Yeah, yeah, they want to be in the room. Yeah, I'll just tell them come downstairs They sit down here with mom and dad just come sit down here with mom and dad. That's that. Tell us about your day I say if you guys don't if you don't you know smart enough, but I make them FaceTime with Sean Yeah They shape up real quick. They really shape up quick and Jason you had an instant Didn't one of your daughters spill some electrolytes recently and you got That was a tough moment for you And now back to the show
Talking about electrolytes doing my incredible research abroad what tell tell us about ladder. What's ladder? Yeah, one is so ladder is a supplement It's a powder form supplement that you put into water Has electrolytes. We also have like pre and post workouts. So what happened was in 2012 I caught cramps during the NBA finals and my legs. I could not get the cramp out So I was able to work with some scientists from Harvard and some other Institutions and we was able to find all organic product that
Helps out with the electrolytes and it gets to the system faster and it stopped. I haven't had I haven't had that problem in nine years After that, so I want some of that. So we have I'll make sure I get something to you guys I'm Jason you guys Jason. We got it recorded here. I'm gonna make sure I get some ladder to you guys Yeah, I would love that LeBron. I want to know like, you know Everybody associates you with the obvious things that we see like the talent and basketball the talent on the screen when you decide to act So what is the thing that would be so surprised like would I ever find you at the Hollywood Bowl listening to some classical music? You know what's funny shot that you say that I love classical music Oh, yeah, I really do like if you if you if you would have happened to pull up on the side of me when I'm not in the dark dark tent car
Yeah, you can catch me out of light listening to some old Beethoven Mozart come on. That's as opposed to the new ones. Yeah You know that I'm fully I'm fully addicted to that stuff and so is Sean Sean's a classically trained pianist, right? Yeah, yeah Wow, but that's cool. I love that now Are you ever listening to classical music on your headphones as you're getting ready to play or you listen to something? That's that gets gets the blood flowing a little bit more. No, I'm listening something get the blood flowing a little bit more Yeah, sure and that's sure and that changes each game
Or is there like a go-to that if you if you need to really get it going? Yeah, like who is it? Do you want to share it? It's not a go. It's like it changes. It's not a go-to You know, you know, I'm listening to a lot of like hardcore hip-hop, you know It could be like either Wu Tang or it'd be like, you know, some some DMX some early DMX I'm sure it's an NWA, you know I want to get to a real or even like Eminem like when he was doing his thing like at a higher level too So like, you know, I tap it to it to a whole another I'm not the father at home with the kids LeBron when I tap it to that mode I'm like get the hell out of my way. I'm ready. I'm ready for war. I'm ready for war. Yeah
You should listen. You should listen to our podcast right before the game Just with your headphones on and you're coming in that's gonna give you the fighting spirit Tell us a little bit about about Space Jam before we before we let you go You've been very generous with your time But I'm very very curious about about this because that's that was a great first film this this this one is Is it pick up where it left off? How is it? How is it different on what? No, it's nice It's different. First of all, it's totally different from the first one that came out 25 years ago But yeah, I was very intimidated just from when I got when the script came to me and I sat it on my desk
I was very intimidated just because I understand, you know, the legacy behind the first one You know, I was I was one that was like it all of it I was 12 years old or 11 when it first came out and love the Looney Tunes Obviously my aspiration for Michael Jordan is out of this world. So very intimidated But I was able to get myself to a point where I was like I want to I want to do this I felt like, you know, the Space Jam legacy is so Iconic and so great. I wanted to be a part of the legacy and obviously the the movie is now called a new legacy It's kind of how I want myself out, but we was able to I worked with a great director of Malcolm Lee
Don Cheeto is in the film as well He's great. Yeah, so I love him. He's helped me out a lot when we were on set, but I just dove into it I gave him, you know, everything to it How'd you like working with all that green screen and all that, you know, I need you to look over here and just trust that later We're gonna we're gonna paint in a little character. You got to look at like a little C-stand with an X on it Exactly. It's like working with Sean. Just a nightmare, right? Yeah, working with Sean. Yeah, or you mean the green screen. Yeah, green screen gives more No, it was a nightmare the first few weeks. Yeah, of course. It's weird, right?
It's so it's super weird because they're like, no, no, no, you're I you're you're you have to be looking up So is that was that like a three-picture deal or we're gonna see how the first one goes or what did you do? Is it just the one? No, no, it was just the one But I mean listen, I've been hearing so much about people's reaction to it so far that's actually seen the movie so far We got an opportunity to private screen it so, you know, if Warner, you know wants to, you know, tackle it again I wouldn't mind, you know, trying to see we could fit the right script in and and keep it going But I think this one is gonna it's gonna surprise a lot of people. This is a family movie It's a family movie with a lot of laughs. Obviously a lot of looniness. I'm dealing with the damn tunes. They crazy
Is your daughter excited about it or are your son's a little too old for it or what? My daughter is super excited about it She doesn't know I mean she's too young to know about the original tunes But now because of her dad she's getting back into it now Was she on the set and was she like wow, yeah, yeah, yeah My whole family stopped by set, you know a few times and they just like wow and my boys is 16 or 14 They only care about how cool that the person that's playing them in the movie looks like dad Does he look like me? Is he wearing my hairstyle? Is he dressing the right way?
Like I don't want somebody playing me and not like so you so you cast some actors to play your sons Yes, we cast the actors to kind of look like my family. We change the names But they are yes, I got an older son a younger son and a daughter and a wife in the movie So yes, it's kind of the same your kids didn't have approval over that casting No, I didn't let them because they would it would have took too long I said dad got to get on the work I and after after a long hours did they did you mix them up? Oh the kids? Yeah, I'm almost brought my fictional family home one time
Long as I don't bring the fictional wife home. I was good. Yeah, right So so LeBron, let me ask you after all this stuff and everything you're doing get back to basketball You've had a lot of success with the Lakers already I don't want to put you on the spot, but I mean you could conceivably just keep going You're so good at what you do. You're still at the top of the game How long do you see yourself playing for the Lakers and how cool is it playing for the Lakers a great storied franchise? Yeah, yeah, I mean listen I truly hope that I can finish my career with the Lakers and how many years that is if it's four or five six
Whatever seven we go, you know, I hope I could continue to play the game You know, I love being in LA my family loves being LA being with a historical franchise like the Lakers or something like it's like me You know being in space gym now I never thought it'd be possible you think about Kareem and magic and will and Jerry Weston and Elgin Baylor Kobe Shaq all the whole list Goes on so Lewis cage, you know, Lewis cage, you know, the great Lewis cage Greatest Lakers fan of all time He's like the greatest Well LeBron can't thank you enough for spending some time with us man. Appreciate you guys
That was really exciting. What a thrill We're all huge huge fans of yours and feel very very flattered that you chose spend some time with us So thank you. I appreciate Jason will shine. I appreciate man. Hopefully see you guys in person soon man. Yeah, that'd be great Yeah, all right, pal wait man. Such a fan Guys, thank you. Bye. Bye. I Could have talked to him all day, but I wanted to respect his his time He had a hard out and I think we just we were like one minute over it But man, I could I could talk to him forever. Yeah, what a cool guy. What a cool career. He's had so far
I have to be honest like I was floored LeBron James like looking at James and living legends so crazy One of the he was one of the earliest people I sent to to Michael our producer to see if we could get and I honestly had Forgotten that I'd put him down as one of the people I'd left to grab on my list And then he sent me a text a couple days ago saying so LeBron's people reached out they can do it on this day But only this time I was like, oh my god, that's right LeBron. Jane Like I've been like a panic for like 36 hours like we're we're gonna be talking to LeBron James and then doing the research looking at his I just like and screw this. I just I can't
There's too much there's it's it's it makes your neck I mean after like only it was only a couple weeks ago that we had to throw and then now we have It's I know because we were so Scraping with Justin in his stories about it growing up, and I don't want to get all the MVP's Justin has gotten You know what I mean, but the rose That way Justin's Wikipedia page Mike That's wrote in himself. There's is you know, there's a there's a there's a comparable element there on the shoulders I don't know why but whenever we meet like just huge gigantic celebrities like LeBron James
I'm so surprised that like they're just normal and down-to-earth people like he's so down to earth even though He's he's literally huge and gigantic. Yeah, yeah, and off the earth He's spent a lot of time off the earth in the air. Yeah, he's got great great leaps are incredible vertical Yeah, all right, but you know we are very generous with our oh my gosh This person was so great, and we love them and they're so down to earth, but genuinely this guy I mean he could he doesn't need to talk to us. He doesn't even know And Jason you're right. We do we do do that a lot We do do that a lot of a lot of the episodes were like oh my god
This person was so great, and we do feel that way in the moment. We're not lying We we really like the people but but this guest could literally qualify as the greatest of all time, and yeah He could he could I could go on forever, but let's not let's let's give the listeners what we promised Which was a little bit more detail on our tour. Yeah, let's start with a tour. Yeah, sorry Let's get back to the tour. Let's get back to the tour. We're going to six cities So we start in Toronto Massey Hall Wednesday February the 2nd and then February 4th We go to Boston, Massachusetts at I'm not sure how to pronounce it Bach or botch Center Wang theater the Wang theater Yep, and then February 5th Brooklyn, New York at Kings Theatre. Yeah, February 8th Chicago, Illinois at the Chicago theater
Yes, Sean, and then where are we going February 9th? Jason, can you guess we're driving? Yeah, we are driving We're gonna we're to dress we're gonna fly between those cities and then from Chicago We're gonna just up the up the coast there a little bit the Lake Coast It's not really on the coast. No, it's more sensual. It's nowhere near the coast, but go ahead Well the coast of the coast of the lake, right? Sure. Sure. No, you're thinking Milwaukee, but no, where are we going? We're gonna end up going Madison, Wisconsin At the Orpheum theater to see Tracy my sister Wednesday February 9th Tracy You better start laying out your outfit right now because you're coming up on stage and then we end on February 12th
Which is Saturday in coming Los Angeles, California at the Orpheum theater, right and just like the show We we can't announce who the guests are those will be a surprise Surprise on the night, but here's what's really really cool for you guys Who have been so awesome and kind and loving to be listening to us all the time We wanted to give you guys something in exchange, which is a head start on tickets So if you go to smartlist.com and put in the password, which is Tracy yeah, well with an e spell with an e t r a c e y You get a head start on tickets before the rest of the general audience
So when you want to go and you want to buy tickets to this tour, you just you use the code tracy t r a c e y Right correct and it's starting today Monday 9 a.m. Eastern through Thursday at 10 p.m. Local time and Tickets go on sale to the public this Friday at 10 a.m. Local time right for all those venues and Thursday July 15th At 10 a.m. Local is the local venue pre-sale. So head to our website to buy tickets and you can get more information at smartlist.com and Again, Wednesday February 2nd Toronto Massey Hall Friday February 4th Boston, Massachusetts
Saturday February 5th Brooklyn, New York Chicago is February 8th Tuesday Wednesday Jason February 9th, you know where we're going just up the coast there, right? Just the coast of just up the up the eastern coast there to Wisconsin Yeah, I guess they didn't have a geography class in the in the in the trailer Universal and then Saturday February 12th back home in Los Angeles with our family and our friends and everybody at the Orvium Theater So guys we're so excited to bring the show to you and we're so So honored that this is even a possibility and we can't wait to have fun with y'all live I hope to see you there. Anyway, see you at the show. I'll see you guys at the show. We're gonna go together, right?
We'll go together. Yeah, let's go together We'll travel together. We'll stay in the same hotel room together. Maybe stay in bed. We'll stay in the same hotel room We're gonna are you driving? We're gonna shake hands. We're gonna bump fist. We're gonna high five people. I know Sean's gonna take a take a bow Probably maybe a call or something. I'm gonna wear tails. I'm gonna wear tails Believe me. Sean's gonna have a spotlight on him. So he's gonna do a fucking song you watch That top hat and cane. I'm set. So anyway, so that's that's all the info that you need to have for our big tour I mean, that's it. Those are the dates in the cities and then the very exciting how great is it that the promo code is Tracy again
TRACY TRACY and that's where you can go and you can buy Buy your tickets. Buy them. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.